into the words as an adaptation of
Stephen Sondheim and James Lapine's Tony
award-winning stage musical which blends
a bunch of Brothers Grimm fairy tales
and throws an original story into the
mix for good measure the classic fairy
tales they get a modern twist of
Cinderella Jack in the Beanstalk Little
Red Riding Hood and Rapunzel while the
new story that links them all together
follows a childless Baker in his wife as
they tried to reverse a curse placed on
them by Wicked Witch now I love a good
musical whether that's classic like
singing in the rain Seven Brides for
Seven Brothers Calamity Jane meet me in
st. Louis and many more or modern movies
like Chicago lame is enchanted once all
pitch perfect
now this isn't director Bob Marshalls
first all-star musical though his
success rates been somewhat hit and miss
there was the brilliant oscar-winning
movie adaptation of candor and ebbs
Chicago with Catherine zeta-jones Renee
Zellweger and Richard Gere then there
was also the not quite so brilliant 9
which was even more star-studded with
Daniel day-lewis Kate Hudson Judi Dench
Mary Ann co-ceo Sophia Loren Nicole
Kidman Penelope Cruz and Fergie from The
Black Eyed Peas few but Marshalls
musical experience doesn't end there
he won a Primetime Emmy for his
choreography on the TV movie of Annie
which he also directed and he's
choreographed movie musicals including
victor/victoria with Julie Andrews and
stage musicals such as cabaret so
basically he's got movie musical form
I've not seen the original stage version
of into the woods but it's been rather
controversial that Disney was adapting
it especially in terms of what they'd
cut and wasn't a musicals tone would
suffer this movie musical is already
getting awards nominations though
including Golden Globes
so does into the woods work as a movie
well it certainly gets you right into
the fairytale mood from the start as it
kicks off with the line once upon a time
in a far-off Kingdom the lines spoken by
an unseen James Corden who plays the
Baker we hear his narration in fact here
and there throughout the film though the
voiceovers never overbearing as it's
used sparingly and fits neatly with the
fairytale setting the Brothers Grimm
fairy tales and Sondheim's musical on
which this film are based are both
pretty dark and although this is a PG
movie from Disney it still manages to
stay on the darkish side okay so it's
not Tim Burton's Sweeney Todd which had
an 18 certificate in the UK and an R
rating in the U
I kind of wonder if at what Tim Burton
would have done with this material
anyway in this into the woods you don't
actually see any violence or bloodshed
on screen with a camera cutting away
before anything nasty happens but while
things aren't necessarily shown on
screen they're certainly not left
totally to our imagination either as
it's pretty clear what's going to happen
so although the violence doesn't feature
explicitly on screen the movie still
feels suitably dark and remember the
movie screenplay was actually written by
james lepine who wrote the book for the
original musical - mixing together
characters and separate fairy tales
makes for some intriguing interactions
and some lovely comic moments - with
some particular standout parts and early
scenes between Little Red Riding Hood
and the Baker in the woods the only
characters I felt were a bit on the
bland side were Rapunzel and her prince
neither is given an awful lot of screen
time and neither has much to do when
they are on screen and there's a thread
in Rapunzel's story that's just kind of
left hanging
having said that Rapunzel's Prince does
have a very funny scene with his brother
Prince Charming and he gets to deliver a
nicely comic line to Rapunzel and
they're all over halfway through the
movie as inventive and witty and clever
as Stephen Sondheim's songs are and into
the woods and they very much are they
totally exist within the setting of the
musical I mean by that they're not
really the kind of tunes you'll find
yourself leaving the cinema singing
whistling or humming as you go as for
the look of the movie the sets the
costumes and most of the effects I
really cannot fault the behind the
scenes crew who do a great job acting
wise into the woods certainly both a
star-studded cast Meryl Streep is just
fabulous as the witch that Streep can
sing is no surprise now of course as
we've seen her sing on screen in the
full-on musical Mamma Mia postcards from
the edge and in Robert Altman's A
Prairie Home Companion as well and just
as you'd expect from an actress of
Streep's caliber she really makes you
believe her which he acts sounds and
looks the part her costume and makeup
look incredible too she's got this bluey
gray matted hair crooked blackened teeth
she's stooped over she's got these long
thick yellowed fingernails and this
ashen of face covered in wrinkles and
it's no wonder given her performance
that she's been nominated for Best
Supporting Actress
in a musical or comedy at the Golden
Globes Anna Kendrick's really got the
musical mania hasn't she what with movie
musicals pitch perfect 2 and the last
five years both out in 2015 that woman
just cannot stop singing and she really
hits the right note as Cinderella and
there's a lovely attention to detail too
in her costumes whether she's in her
scrubbing the floor outfit or kitted out
in a golden dress for the king's
festival Chris Pine gives a cracking
performance of Cinderella's Prince
really capturing his vanity and
arrogance in a lovely comic turn he's
already flexed his comedic muscles
recently in Horrible Bosses 2 we put on
a hilariously unhinged show and he gets
to develop that into the woods with some
lovely scenes with his brother who
simply called Rapunzel's Prince lookout
in particular for the song agony were
they desperately trying to outdo each
other Emily Blunt reunites with her
Devil Wears Prada co-star Meryl Streep
in a rather different role though she's
still treated pretty poorly by Luke's
character Blunt plays the Baker's wife
who's dying to have a baby but hasn't
been able to if you've seen her in
anything from looper to the five-year
engagement or the young victoria you'll
know Blunt is a fantastic actress but do
you also know she can sing well she can
and very well - thank you very much in
fact this isn't her first time belting
out a song on screen she actually won a
Golden Globe for her role in the BBC
drama called Gideon's daughter where she
also had to carry a tune
anyway I love her in into the woods for
the same reason I love her in just about
any role you always believe her and
whatever she's playing and she's been
nominated for Best Actress in a Musical
or Comedy at the Golden Globes - James
Corden is great as the Baker portraying
his character with ease you may know him
for writing and stirring and hip British
comedy Gavin and Stacey and of course
he's going to be replacing Craig
Ferguson as host of The Late Late Show
in 2015 again this isn't his first
musical venture he starred as amateur
opera singer and Britain's Got Talent
winner Paul Potts in the movie one
chance and going back to the late 90s he
played the lead singer in a boy band in
the TV comedy boys unlimited which was
actually co-written by David Walliams
and Matt Lucas Johnny Depp puts in a
brief appearance as the lascivious wolf
Depp's no stranger to Sondheim musicals
having starred in Tim Burton's movie
version of Sweeney Todd the Demon Barber
of Fleet Street and he's also worked
with into the woods director Rob
Marshall
for on the 4th Pirates of the Caribbean
movie on Stranger Tides but I'll try not
to hold that against him I love the
understated way they've styled his wolf
he's got a fedora hat with little ears
poking out a 1940's inspired gray blue
fur jacket over similarly colored shirt
and tie bushy eyebrows mustache and oh
yeah a tail and I love the
matter-of-fact interaction between his
wolf and Red Riding and it's also
perfectly natural when they meet good
day young ladies good day mr. wolf which
I think adds the Cundall kimura's
Christine Baranski play Cinderella's
stepmother again she's got musical form
she works alongside Streep in Mamma Mia
with into the woods director of martial
on the movie Chicago and she starred in
various productions on stage though she
doesn't have a lot to do in the movie
what she does do she does very well so
to sum up as far as Rob Marshall's
musicals go I still prefer Chicago but
into the woods is an enjoyably dark tale
with a sense of humor great performances
and gorgeous sets and costumes into the
woods gets 4 out of 5 flicks now I want
to know what did you think of into the
woods have you seen the stage musical
how do you think the movie compares and
watch your favorite movie musicals let
me know in the comments below and don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
for more of my weekly film reviews and
interviews thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you